I'm going to be spending an entire day
living like a clicker from the last of
us to do this I made a costume and tried
my best to immerse myself in the life of
a
clicker oh God it was actually pretty
easy to make and it only cost about 20
bucks I started out with a plastic
Halloween mask that already looks
terrifying and I duct taped some
cardboard to the top to act as a base
for the mask then I went outside to
spray some foam onto the mask because
apparently the foam is toxic and it
might cause lung damage or even kill me
but anyways it looked pretty good so
then I went back inside to get to
carving this part actually took quite a
bit of time because I really wanted it
to look as much like a clicker as
possible but once I finished that I got
to painting and after about four coats
of paint it was time for the finishing
touches last but not least I cut a set
of zombie teeth in half and glued them
to the bottom of the Mask so it would
look just like a clicker that's had its
entire skull split in two and now for
the finished
product oh I definitely can't see